Dennis l'énergie donc est un facteur clé
pour Poutine là qui renvoie la
responsabilité aux Occidentaux bon la
rhétorique ne change pas oui bien
évidemment mais surtout il faut bien
comprendre que Liam est un de guerre qui
sont menées par la Russie il a une
guerre contre l'Ukraine bien évidemment
donc cette guerre et lui aussi elle est
depuis quelques jours énergétique car on
a bien vu les Russes ont du mal à
avancer sur le terrain notamment dans
les régions de personnes dont on vient
de voir les images mais aussi un peu
partout dans le pays donc pour eux plus
question de manger sur le terrain tant
qu'il y a encore la défense ukrainienne
qui fonctionne très bien donc leur
stratégie c'était de détruire notamment
donc c'est bon de l'énergie donc les
stations de ces différents points de
infrastructure claires sur le terrain et
vous avez bien parlé de la ville de Le
Vif qui lui aussi a été épargné jusque
il y a quelques jours de ces frappe là
maintenant celui-ci cette ville qui est
tirée pourquoi parce qu'il y a encore
quelques mois c'était là où se trouvait
toutes les ambassades qui ont été
évoqués depuis qui est il y a bien
évidemment aussi
des services d'un renseignement qui sont
également eux basés dans cette ville là
donc c'est important de ne pas
uniquement et couper du coeur en Kiev
qui est bien évidemment une vie clé
aussi de couper différentes huiles pour
effectivement qu'il y a moins d'aide sur
le terrain qui arrive pour des
différentes armées ukrainiennes dans
différentes régions par contre il y a 2e
guerre et Lucie énergétique contre
l'Europe et ça et les Poutine également
prononcé des mots assez fort que c'est
l'Europe qui est coupable de cette
situation là ils sont la tête l'homme
qui est en tête de gaz proma monsieur
Miller a dit que il y a plusieurs villes
européennes qui vont gêler pendant cet
thé vert là donc en fait il y a vraiment
cette pression de la part des Russes
pour faire avancer des situations sur le
terrain mélangeuse c'est aussi de quoi
de diviser les Européens
à force à terme de dire voilà la guerre
a trop duré et donc on veut renouer avec
Poutine ça c'était un peu la stratégie
depuis le début de la guerre on a bien
vu que il y a eu des différentes
mouvements politiques en Europe même si
c'était plus comme avant le 24 février
qui était plutôt contre l'Ukraine et un
soutien de la Russie maintenant Poutine
nous voit bien qu'il y a cette unité
importante qui s'est battu en Europe il
veut plus que ça a lieu donc oui
effectivement lui utilisait tous les
leviers pour que le soutien à l'Europe
c'est le plus vite possible le tiens à
l'Ukraine pardon c'est le plus vite
possible on est le